des palettes bloque toujours l'entrée de
l'école de la montagne voeckler les
parents d'élèves continuent leur
mobilisation
la réunion avec la municipalité hier a
permis des avancées
un accord a été trouvé les enfants
déménageront à l'école de bellevue
mais il y à un blocage sur la solution
transitoire que propose la mairie
même si le maire nous a dit qu'il a
trouvé une solution pour qu'on soit
accueilli à l'école de bellevue
il voulait tout de même que les enfants
aillent à l'école de cadettes et à
l'école des algues marines pour qu'ils
ne restent pas trop longtemps sans aller
à l'école il nous a assuré que malgré ça
que les enfants allaient déménager avant
la fin du mois dans l'école de bellevue
sachant dans ces conditions que ça leur
ferait de déménagement dans le moins
donc nous dans ces conditions là nous
n'avons pas à accepter les choses ont
évolué rapidement puisque désormais la
ville a abandonné 7 propositions
transitoires de mettre les élèves dans
deux établissements scolaires différents
pour se concentrer sur l'école de
bellevue au départ comme la majorité des
enfants avec le bout et très peu 33
élèves habitent le bourg et 19 habite la
montagne nous avons pensé tout
naturellement accueil où tout le monde
au bout parce qu'il ya de la place pour
les accueillir avec les mêmes maîtresse
les mêmes petits camarades les mêmes
uniformes bref les mêmes moyens mais ils
veulent absolument aller dans ce
quartier de bellevue et bien nous
suzanne homme de paix de dialogue
donc j'ai recherché j'ai fait déjà deux
réunions avec eux et nous avons trouvé
une solution qui permet d'apaiser
d'apaiser tout pour l'instant l'école de
bellevue et fermer la préfecture et le
rectorat devront donner leur aval pour
le déménagement
les parents d'élèves pour leur part ont
décidé de rester mobilisés jusqu'à ce
que le transfert ait lieu